good evening the corona virus
is the biggest threat this country has
faced for decades and this country is
not alone all over the world were seeing
the devastating impact of this invisible
killer and so tonight I want to update
you on the latest steps
we're taking to fight the disease and
what you can do to help and I want to
begin by reminding you why the UK has
been taking the approach that we have
without a huge national effort to halt
the growth of this virus there will come
a moment when no health service in the
world could possibly cope because I
won't be enough ventilators and life
intensive care beds enough doctors and
nurses and as we've seen elsewhere in
other countries that also have fantastic
health care systems that is the moment
of real danger to put it simply if too
many people become seriously unwell at
one time the NHS will be unable to
handle it meaning more people are likely
to die not just from coronavirus but
from other illnesses as well so it's
vital to slow the spread of the disease
because that is the way we reduce the
number of people needing hospital
treatment at any one time so we can
protect the NHS's ability to cope and
save more lives and that's why we've
been asking people to stay at home
during this pandemic and though huge
numbers are complying and I thank you
all the time has now come for us all to
do more from this evening I must give
the British people a very simple
instruction you must stay at home
because the critical thing we must do to
stop the disease spreading between
households that is why people will only
be allowed to leave their home for the
following very limited purposes shopping
for basic necessities as infrequently as
possible one form of exercise a day for
example a run walk or cycle alone with
of your household any medical need to
provide care or to help a vulnerable
person and traveling to and from work
but only whether this is absolutely
necessary and cannot be done from home
that's all these are the only reasons
you should leave your home you should
not be meeting friends if your friends
asked you to meet
you should say no you should not be
meeting family members who do not live
in your home you should not be going
shopping except for essentials like food
and medicine and you should do this as
little as you can and use food delivery
services where you can if you don't
follow the rules
the police will have the powers to
enforce them
including through fines and dispersing
gatherings to ensure compliance with the
government's instruction to stay at home
we will immediately close all shops
selling non-essential goods including
clothing and electronic stores and other
premises including libraries playgrounds
and outdoor gyms and places of worship
will stop all gatherings of more than
two people in public
excluding people you live with and will
stop all social events including
weddings baptisms and other ceremonies
but excluding funerals parks will remain
open for exercise but gatherings will be
dispersed no prime minister wants to
enact measures like this I know the
damage that this disruption is doing and
will do to people's lives to their
businesses and to their jobs and that's
why we've produced a huge and
unprecedented program of support both
for workers and for business and I can
assure you that we will keep these
restrictions under constant review we
will look again in three weeks and relax
them if the evidence shows we are able
to but at present there are just no easy
options the
ahead is hard and it is still true that
many lives will sadly be lost and yet it
is also true that there is a clear way
through day by day we are strengthening
our amazing NHS with 7500 former
clinicians now coming back to the
service with the time you buy by simply
staying at home we are increasing our
stocks of equipment we are accelerating
our search for treatments were
pioneering work on a vaccine and we are
buying millions of testing kits that
will enable us to turn the tide on this
invisible killer I want to thank
everyone who is working flat-out to beat
the virus everyone from the supermarket
staff to the transport workers to the
carers to the nurses and doctors on the
frontline but in this fight we can be in
no doubt that each and every one of us
is directly enlisted each and every one
of us is now obliged to join together to
halt the spread of this disease to
protect our NHS and to save many many
thousands of lives and I know that as
they have in the past so many times the
people of this country will rise to that
challenge and we will come through it
stronger than ever we will be a corona
virus and we will beat it together and
therefore I urge you at this moment of
national emergency to stay at home
protect our NHS and save lives thank you